[Musique]
au fond de ma course fuir nos mères
profondes macoutes tout jury renault
mais pour avoir le coeur malfamé le
chrtr malfamé
quoi vincennes
il ya des petites fleurs ya des petites
fleurs
il ya des coffres 20
on boit de mon coeur
kwal mon coeur du camp il ya plus de
vingt ans mon tonneau contient plus de
alors mon tonneaux
dans mon tonneaux ils n'ont pas peur de
boire mon nombre de boire mon nous
ouah
saint cloud où il ya des possibles
il ya des petits plats
ad comme aux voix de mon coeur
quad monde
il m'accompagne à la mairie je
m'accompagne
à la mairie
[Musique]
l'amérique chaque fois que je me marie
que ne m'a rien
au bois
non il ya des petits plats
g
aux voix de mon coeur pur
là
de chaque fois pleut mains vides
allemand
chapeau amplement
fidèlement
suivent mon entraînement
angleterre
au bois
fait des petits
il ya des
holmes
moi de mon coeur
wang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]